it's more than three months since
richard corrigay's body was found
the circumstances around his
disappearance and death still aren't
known
but as police continue their
investigation they too are under the
spotlight
and the probe into how the met first
handled the case has now seen
two members of staff served with
misconduct notices
for potentially failing to pass on new
and relevant
information the internal investigation
was launched after complaints made by
the 19 year old's mother
who accused the met of not treating her
seriously when she reported her son
missing
her son disappeared after leaving home
in west london on march the 22nd
the student who had sickle cell disease
was last seen on cctv that night in
laoton and essex
following an extensive police search his
body was found two weeks later
in a pond in epping forest nearby
richard's mother contacted the police
the day after he vanished but he wasn't
officially recorded as missing until 24
hours later
reacting to the misconduct notices she
said it is encouraging to hear that they
are doing something
because i kept calling and at one point
a police officer told me to stop
this news provides some vindication of
what i said all along
about how slow the police were to act
misconduct notices don't necessarily
mean disciplinary action will follow
but this is a welcome step for a family
that's still searching for answers
iva bennett sky news